women do judge the hell out of other  women  i've worked in  sorry you know i worked on the view  a lot of estrogen going on there i also  worked on a show at fox that was all  women  women are tough on other women in fact  some of the  most um how do what's the word that i  use here some of the most venomous  bosses i've had have been female there's  a lot of competition in the air there's  a lot of judgment there's a lot of focus  on people always think it's the guys  that focus on the physical appearance of  women  no one will criticize a woman  like a woman i mean she will get down to  the bobby pin in the back of your hair  that is not in right guys won't even  notice that guys don't notice 90 of  what's wrong i'll look it i'll leave the  house and i'll look at my husband i'll  be like oh babe you see how that little  he's like what are you what  what what are you talking about  girl will spot a zit on your face a mile  away and be like girlfriend didn't get  that cream from cbs